vous pensez qu'ils doivent le diffuser
on en a déjà parlé mais là je pense que
dans la nuit les semaines passent et qui
doivent la nuit de la nuit et moi j'ai
vu le premier épisode en avant-première
hors des dates faut arrêter de dire
qu'il met pas en avant michel fourniret
dans cette fiction sur salto ça vous
n'aurez pas regarder le quinquenat voilà
le premier épisode toujours 50 minutes
ils mettent plus de 50% du temps en
avant michel fourniret donc vous êtes
déjà dans ce cas ci n'ont jamais fait
preuve de maîtrise et la rue avant de
migrer lac en avant michel fourniret et
sa camionnette ou des scènes avec lui la
première scène c'est l'enlèvement d'une
petite fille elle par michel fourniret
terrible à revoir pour les victimes et
vous ne pouvez pas je le redis vous ne
pouvez pas starifié un pédophile dans
une fiction
alors justement on à selim qui est avec
nous fils de michel fourniret et merci
donc aux librairies santoro vous êtes
journaliste co auteur du fils de l'ogre
avec céline justement vous êtes seul
journaliste à avoir interviewé michel
fourniret en prison selim et je sais que
vous êtes vraiment en colère
vous êtes déjà venu nous voir dans
balances ton post aujourd'hui on va
s'intéresser vraiment à la fiction de
tf1 du 15 mars
vous êtes contre cette fiction et que
vous êtes contre la diffusion de cette
fiction de la traque
c'est libre pourquoi pas un film tu
respectes victimes ont pu ensuite le top
100 n'a pas de respect pour les gens qui
disent plus loin on peut connaître leurs
difficultés pour ça c'est à croire que
le fils de michel fourniret nice à ça et
c'est sacré est ce que vous l'avez vu
séisme j'ai pas vu je ne voulais pas
envie de voir même pour vous c'est cette
ces voix là vous n'avez pas envie de
voir ça non moi je connais pas faire un
film je suis pas vu les façons ils
peuvent pas dire tout puisque tout n'a
pas été dit il ya plein de choses qui
aurait été passé sous silence qu'elle
n'a pas été médiatisée la sphère est
encore en cours d'instruction n'est pas
finie donc pas tout en plus le titre
la traque aucun trac il était libre
si la jeune fille en 2003 ne s'étaient
pas évadés si les automobilistes qui n'a
lui pas pu la black edition à liberté
toujours positif donc pour vous c'est
trop tôt ce téléfilm où il n'aurait
jamais fallu le faire
reportage bon d'accord mais passe
pourtant il lui faut penser que est-ce
que vous pensez que votre père pour lui
ça va être son jour de gloire le 15 mars
de voir qu'à une fiction sur tf1 le
concernant je ne pense pas qu'ils sont
au courant qu'ils sortent ce n'est pas
tout mais si le cours entre le chasseur
ou les simples sur internet ici
déjà le fait que tout c'est l'ultime n'a
pas été identifié on sache pas le nombre
exact de victimes demandent de victimes
ou dit que ma main est fou et
incalculables pensait pas qu'il y en a
donc dans 20 ans et est souvent un cadre
on va dire c'est peut être méchant plus
sereinement
ils vous ont pas du tout consulter les
réalisateurs les gens qui ont écrit la
fiction pas du tout non scission
attendue à trouver un match honorable
ils n'ont pas essayé de joindre le mans
ça c'est fou c'est assez c'est
incroyable et vous vous vous savez même
pas si vous apparaissez dans la fiction
il apparaît dans la villa navarre et
quand il a 14 ans et ils n'ont même pas
ils n'auraient pas consulté donc c'est
un crois moi ce que dit selim ce soir
c'est fou que lui-même un 10 qui n'a pas
envie de voir ça pour les victimes
un et vous pensez que les familles des
victimes et aux librairies santoro vous
êtes le seul journaliste à avoir
interviewé michel fourniret en prison on
en parlait il ya un instant penser que
lui pour lui le 15 mars parce qu'il va
le savoir
forcément ça va c'est pour 8 ccc un
hommage concurrents mais complètement
moi j'essaye s'aggraverait gg une lettre
de michel fourniret qui nous a envoyés
durant notre longue relation épistolaire
est allé se recueillir sur wii ne savais
pas que j'étais journaliste je me
cachais derrière celle mpo c'est
d'entrer dans ses pensées sachant que
c'est un manipulateur sur vous on la
manipule et moi j'ai une aide de l'ue
dans laquelle il écrit à moi désolation
auquel il l'écrit stricto sensu il est
fier de tout ça il est fier qu'on parle
de lui ça le fait exister c'est
quelqu'un qui a un ego
pour dix mois le 15 mars je vais tu l'as
tu as sans doute de fiction sur sur tf1
vous arriveront ils
vous êtes contre porto pierre goy aussi
complètement mais c'est d'autant plus
grave que le sait vraiment trompeur
comme fiction c'est pas juste une
fiction c'est une fiction elle-même
adaptée d'un roman 100% fictionnelle il
faut avoir le préambule du roman dont il
tf1 a acheté les droits ont regardé ce
qui est écrit en préambule
si ce livre est basé sur l' affaire
fourniret s'il suit au plus près les
faits tels qu'ils ont été révélés lors
du procès cet ouvrage est avant tout une
oeuvre de fiction les pensées et les
propos prêtés à monique olivier à michel
fourniret ainsi qu'aux différents
personnages de cette histoire relève de
la pure fiction et de la seule création
littéraire
c'est du pur divertissement cerner ce
qu'on peut se divertir avec la sphère
fourniret non mais c'est ça vous ne lui
a pas proposé devant le chili peut pas
le vent mais ils me l'ont dit ils n'ont
même pas eu la correction de lui
proposer
oui c'est alors il est sûr salto je vous
le dis voilà sur la plateforme ou si oui
si on envoie du jeu demande une pétition
en ligne tout arrêt de ce projet ils
nous ont après répondu aux questions de
l'expression qui n'ont pas signifié par
rapport à ça on a mis un avocat pour lui
ont demandé une action pacifique
m karim la voix fait d'accord et ce
qu'il a droit est ce que vous pensez
qu'il peut vous enlever parce que la cie
selim mais un avocat et qui me fait une
mise en demeure et qui demande à ne pas
être dans le film et ils vont dire que
c'est de la fiction je pense que ça va
être compliqué souligné que j'ai
d'ailleurs une erreur qui a été
dites par monsieur jean michel merle
l'autre soir toutes les victimes de
michel fourniret ne sont pas mortes
il a commis 15 agressions sexuelles dans
les années 80 et la norme il ya daïna le
ghana qui a quand même réussi récemment
faire retirer de la vente la bd de
stéphane bourgoin le serial menteur
comme le dit paris match elle a réussi à
faire retirer sa de la vente ou quoi
donc c'est possible ça existe vous vous
êtes vous êtes choqués de section pour
un site pour les familles des victimes
ou plus parce que oui parce que michel
fourniret ce soir là va se dire j'ai
réussi mon vin je l'avais gg je suis un
héros ce soir là c'est les deux mais je
peux vous dire que daïna le gagnant dont
je vous parlais le vis très très mal le
fait qu'une section elle est allée à
fond derrière céline exactement ces
lignes vous avez vous avez rencontré des
victimes de votre père qui sont encore
vivantes
non justement je me mets un peu mes
proches de victimes vous voir un film
qui va sortir comme ça sur l'homme qui a
tué votre fils j'imaginais ça c'est
invivable
elle soutient c'est l'homme que tu es ma
fille en fait un film sans lui on le
passe à tous les besoins vont gagner de
l'argent sur ça passionnant et c'est de
l'argent va être reversée à des
associations
non je ne crois pas non mais non c'est
libre vous aviez vous avez quel rapport
avec votre père parce que c'est vrai que
tout se demande c'est vrai que cccd quel
rapport avec lui maintenant je suis plus
avec lui plutôt nation tu contactes on
avait un contact comme a dit olivier
l'épistolaire c'était pour la vivre l
enquête
la construction par la vengeance on va
dire après dans l'enfance jetèrent père
pour moi ce tintin en main ça faisait
pas ce qu'il veut non pas au courant
après j'ai appris récemment qu'ils en
parlent et atteindre que josé de sortie
avec eux mes chiens j'ai pas de rappel
de saint lô culte tout ça c'était
quelqu'un de normal pour moi c'était un
père noël n'était pas proche il te
paternel mais la tangente respect papa
maman il travaillait beaucoup à la
maison brûle travaux la maison est en
chantier
mais sinon je m'attache travailler le
même choix
les poussines de mauvaise note vous
apprenez le jour de son interpellation
qui est votre papa en fait c'est ça je
opération du jour où elle est arrêtée je
crois bien il ya des voitures de police
d'endroits la maison minutes ne veut
rien dire je sais pas c'est plus tard
que j'ai appris la vérité avait été dite
en lever une fille qui s'est échappé et
c'est seulement après l'arrestation de
monique dans les médias que j'ai appelé
tout ce qui s'est passé au lit selim ça
cesse ça lui fait mal ce cette fiction
qui m'arrive est là dans quelques jours
est-ce qu'ils appréhendent quand vous
vous sentez vous ce que vous êtes voilà
très produit sur dix qui la présentent
ce moment ce 15 mars
bien sûr bien sûr il ressent beaucoup
d'empathie pour les victimes
il n'a pas ce détachement d'ailleurs
quand on a fait l'émission de bâle reste
il reste avec chagnollaud il a été très
marqué par la fille d'emile louis et il
sait que lui laisse est un survivant et
il a quand même réussi à réussir malgré
tout il incarne un symbole d'espoir mais
il sait que ce n'est pas le cas tout le
monde notamment deux de ses proches qui
ont été impactés aussi par cette affaire
donc aujourd'hui c'est pour ça qu'il est
si actif et qu'il entend voilà faire
valoir la le respect pour les familles
des victimes
un légitime en soi dans votre livre le
fils drogue vous nous citer un moment
vous dit la veille au soir il est tombé
sur touche pas à mon poste
l'émission animée par cyril hanouna au
cours de laquelle un chroniqueur ne se
serait pas privé de balancer hilare tu
ne préférerait pas être avec fourniret
dans une cellule plutôt qu'avec verdez
c'est encore jean michel mr oui c'est ça
rigole et ça c'est le genre de phrase
qui sait linky qui vous qui vous blesse
même s'ils ont perdu connaissance
c'est un sujet c'est ça c'est normal
bien sûr oui c'est pas un statut pour
les ultimes potabilité y est ce que
michel fourniret et monique olivier
ce soit aussi servi de vous comme appât
pour attirer une petite fille
notre mission at elle seule ces textes
moi j'ai aucun souvenir de tout ceci dit
je vais probablement occulter tous ces
souvenirs je sais pas ce que j'ai vu
c'est un projet qu'on à faire plutôt de
l'hypnose point c'est tout
replonger dans ses souvenirs ne pas
ressentir dès l'été mais par exemple un
moment et est sujette une jeune fille au
pair maintenant entendu parler je suis
aux perses qui va pour moi donc tu es
certain magnin j'étais à ma part je dois
pas bébé enfant en jetant céline fait
quoi dans la vie aujourd'hui
d'où tombent d'accord vous arrivez à
travailler les gens savent qui vous êtes
ou pas non voulait pas voilà iront quand
vous montre ça me fait tellement
multiples céline fournir est pendante
j'ai changé des ch'tis salle et sur
l'île de ré impossible pour vous de
porter ce nom ça arrivait à être heureux
dans la vie raffin a essayé d'être
heureux en tout cas essayer de vivre une
vie normale mais maintenant je suis tout
blanc justin chau j'avoue vois je suis
un stand a tout dit voici de trouver des
vérités c'est de rebondir sur
l'actualité
sur les choses qui ne sont pas dites
adieu trouvé beaucoup de gestion c'est
ça mon oncle temps en rien une seule
chose pour me mettre en avant
si tu nous tiens avec ça va arriver très
prochainement accord va très bien vous
viendrez nous voir juste si vous aviez
tous les deux le téléfilm il va être
diffusée 15 mars franchement je vois pas
comment il peut ne peut pas être diffusé
si vous aviez quelque chose à dire ce
soir aux dirigeants de tf1 qui nous
regardent c'est certainement
qu'est ce que vous leur diriez pour
essayer de les convaincre de ne pas
diffuser ce téléfilm le 15 mars et au
réalisateur yves rénier qui regardent
certainement l'émission quel toupet quel
toupet je vois pas je vois rien d'autre
à dire quoi pourquoi vraiment c'est à
l'orée du sprint et au commissaire
moulin qui est une fiction 100% fiction
d'accord aurait dû rester dans ce
créneau quand je vois pas ce qu'il vient
faire dans dans la sphère fournirai quoi
s'est passé pas olivier marchal il a pas
là la carrière d'un flip quoi donc
qu'est ce qu'il vient faire là dedans de
quoi il se mêle choix aurait été réglé
ma feuille de laurier accepté oui il est
peut-être mieux placé pour parler des
gens d'affaires d'ailleurs il s'exprime
très souvent sur les affaires du monde
acceptera yves rénier avant franchement
il fait un bon travail mais c'est la
fiction mais pourquoi ne pas changer le
nom de michel fourniret par exemple
pourquoi
en fait ça ils l'ont fait récemment m6
pour xavier dupont de ligonnès ils ont
eu la correction de changer les noms
c'est pas le cas ici
puis c'est une affaire qui est encore en
cours d'instruction il ya un nombre
incalculable de victimes
il faut il faut arrêter de se limiter à
ce palmarès qui a édité par la justice
et la presse
on sait très bien qu'il est faux il ya
d'autres victimes encore donc totalement
cette jeune fille au pair que selim dont
céline se rappelle de la présente c'est
ton simple au absolument rien même pas
le prénom percée aucune famille n'a
revendiqué sa disparition mais elle
existe il se rappelle de sa présence et
regardez nous perd non non pas du tout
non selim qu'est ce que vous diriez vous
à aux gens de tf1 au réalisateur ce soit
pour qu'ils diffusent pas cette fiction
qui s'imaginent ça m'a fait que c'est un
match qu'ils vont comprendre ça peut
faire c'est quand vous avez vu ça vous
étiez vraiment énervé oui je le pense
film que si le criminel
si vous avez aimé dans le projet si vous
avez intégré au projet vous auriez dit
oui ou pas au lit ils ont essayé ils ont
demandé à ce qu'on prenne contact par
avocats interposés mais parce qu'on
voyait venir la chose qu'est ce qui lui
aurait proposé de devenir consultant
technique pour leurs fictions il acheté
avec leur argent ben non non on ne
préférait pas répondre à un avocat
maître karim la wii fit qui s'occupera
du dossier de selim mais il était hors
de question que d'accepter des trucs ans
et en technique juste pour de l'argent
essayez vous l'auriez pas fait alors
mine ity une fiction c'est parce qu'il
aime c'est aussi dit tout n'a pas été
toujours les médias il va pas être au
courant de tout donc le film s'est
investie d'une fiction alors au lit vous
avez contribué à ce que michel fourniret
je reconnus coupables du meurtre de
nouvelles victimes
je sais qu'il ya un documentaire vous
êtes en train de faire tous les deux
j'espère que minarets nous montrer des
extraits très très vite les verts